[Music]
joining me today is an author a
professor and evolutionary behavioral
scientist
Amanda wears a bow tie when speaking to
the Canadian Parliament and a guy with
an incredible tan dad said welcome back
to the reuben report it's so nice to be
back thanks Dave
the can I don't know that our cameras I
don't know that you tuned through the
wires and the tubes or whatever gets it
out to the people I don't know that it
can take that level of tan they're just
you being next to me you're going to get
ten I hope so because I've never felt
whiter than I feel right now that is
that good Lebanese skin that you a
doesn't do alright so you've been on the
show many times you were my my first you
were on the first test show of the
Reuben report you were on the first
panel we ever did we've done one-on-ones
a couple times from getting to know you
you have just been in sort of what I
would call the fight that is happening
now the free-speech fight the the fight
for enlightenment values for liberal
values this whole thing but I thought it
a nice way to start would be you happen
to be on vacation right now right you
are in the midst of a five-week SoCal
vacation and how important is that when
you are someone that puts yourself out
there all the time as I said you just
spoke to Canadian Parliament you're at
Google do in a talk I mean just as
someone that's always out there to shut
down how important very important
although I am I've done a few shows
while I'm here so there is a bit of work
interspersed within the vacation it's
terribly important not so much for going
to the beach but for disconnecting from
being available to the public now I
always promised my wife that I will
absolutely not check a single thing I
mean and then usually that last three
four or five days and then I succumb to
the temptation but that I think is
fundamentally the most important part of
my vacation which is to not weigh in
every hour on Twitter to just disconnect
yeah so profoundly important how do you
balance between the academic things that
you care about and all the stuff that
we're going to talk about for the for
the next hour or so and just being human
because I feel like that's what people
are having trouble dealing with and I
mean that from people that work
blue-collar jobs to people that are
doing
I level math stuff I feel like people
are having trouble separating like just
all the noise from reality so I
basically have in professionally
speaking I have really two hats that I
wear that of a professor with all that
that entails which if I only did that it
would keep me busy 18 hours a day and
then there is my public intellectual hat
that I wear over the past few years I
feel that a large part of my time has
been taken up by the ladder and now I'm
trying to kind of rein that in so to
still remain a viable voice and the
battle of public ideas but I need to
sort of go back to some of the
fundamentals the last stuff now you're
never giving it giving it up but it
takes time as you know right to build an
audience to get people excited about
what you have to say it takes a lot of
effort and so I don't think I have the
magical recipe yet but I try to every
day do a little book yeah when you've
made that shift which probably was right
around when I met you met whatever we
did on Twitter however you connect with
someone on Twitter you know whatever
that is now four years ago or so when
you made that sort of shift from
academic to someone that was going to
speak their mind publicly and fight with
people publicly videos and interviews
and all that stuff
did you realize how much of a not not
just a time set but a an important piece
of your life it was going to become I
didn't you know I'm very much of a
purist so I'm just excited by things
like a child right so I discovered that
there's this thing called social media
that allows me to advertise my ideas
with all sorts of people meet people
that I would have otherwise never meet
like they Ruben and countless others
even random strangers that I get to meet
who send me beautiful gifts and I get to
know them well who tell me stuff that's
personal in their lives so I never
thought that that would be possible but
I'm amazed at the power of the medium I
have and I don't say this an arrogant
man just walking down the street and
probably you get this probably 10 times
more than I do the number of people who
recognise you who come up to you who say
they love your work or you know we could
be on the beach and I'll be stuck with
it I could be in a bathroom and someone
will say hey Godfather and so that's
nothing worse than that when you're
peeing it's vanity the guys are you it's
right there
but that I look at that with a bit of
humility and that it's incredible that
we have these platforms which five 10
years ago a guy like me and academia
could have never hoped to have and so
it's been wonderful it's been a blessing
yeah is there are real silver lining to
everything that's going on now which is
people feel like everyone's Dumber in
fighting all the time and you know I'm a
firm believer that most of us 80% of us
want the same simple things and to live
decent lives and and have some food and
have some money and be able to go on
vacation have some sex and just whatever
whatever those basics are but the silver
lining while it sounds so crazy that
obviously if people are recognizing you
and rewarding you for the work you do it
shows that there's an intellectual
thirst I'm see if it's not being given
to you by the mainstream media but it
shows that it's out there absolutely I
mean shows like like you know that are
not mainstream I think eventually this
will be the mainstream it it amazes me
how the mainstream media has sort of
doubled down you know to use a term that
we might talk about later ostrich logic
but they understand and refuse to sort
of recognize some of the dynamics look
anything that promotes more discussion
is great I only wish that people were
sometimes a bit nicer Yeah right
I think but perhaps they haven't evolved
to be nicer but maybe that's that should
be your next book maybe that should be
the evolution of evil online I mean I
think we both most of the time do this
right we're able to brush it off but it
takes it takes a toll you're not reading
about your in my case my weight my
Judaism my I mean it just endless
you know nasty things that are written
about you yeah I wish people would
recognize that both of us and many of us
who play in this marketplace of idea are
really doing it with purely few reasons
to contribute to a discussion and if
people could learn to be a bit nicer we
would all be richer for it yeah I mean I
wish it but I don't sense that coming
down my hike alright so we're gonna
we're gonna do a lot of stuff here but I
think just first because it couches
everything else on the free-speech front
you've become one of the few people that
I know of at least on the public side in
Canada that are really fighting
the free speech battle of course the
real high-profile guy also is Jordan
Peterson also at the academic level of
course what is happening in Canada right
now I mean it seems pretty scary
actually when you hear some of this
stuff Canada I think is desperately
trying to become the number one social
justice for your country in the world
it's trying to catch up to Germany and
Sweden in part because we have a prime
minister who very much epitomizes those
positions and so the endless tsunami of
these types of positions are difficult
to keep up with you mentioned earlier
that I had appeared in front again
Senate to testify maybe I could mention
this very briefly
so there's a big you're here to tell me
what you think that if you don't have
that fill c16 is a bill that is now
since passed both Jordan Peterson and I
in separate sessions have been asked to
appear to discuss some of our concerns
with the bill the bill basically refers
to incorporating together identity and
gender expression within hate crime laws
that if you target someone based on
their gender identity or gender
expression then it's hateful and so then
you know I guess the the penalty would
be ratcheted up and I appeared in front
of the Canadian Senate to basically
argue that the way that it was worded is
so vague and potentially so dangerous
that literally anything that I teach in
my evolutionary psychology courses could
be construed as quote transphobic
systemic violence and the reason why I
say quotes because those are terms that
a Harvard pamphlet the LGBTQ office at
Harvard had put out a pamphlet where
they argued that people who support
quote fixed binaries and biological
essentialism fixed binaries is
male/female familiar biological
essentialism is arguing that there are
no biological realities evolved
realities innate sex differences if you
promulgate these types of position you
are actually engaging in quote
transphobic systemic violence that's not
that's not allegorical it's not
metaphorical you literally are being
transphobic ly violent and so I argued
that anything that I say in my course
when I walk into my course and
introduced the concept of sexual
selection and how sex specific traits
evolve I only use words like male and
female I don't refer to the non-binary
and non gender and so on
so any person in the room could say hey
and a 13 week course you never once
recognize my personhood you're engaging
in transphobic systemic violence the
answer to this very sober presentation
that I gave was that one of the Canadian
senators accuse me of being pro genocide
and where did that Avrom because
apparently the fact that I was not
supporting the bill somehow through a
gargantuan leap of logic you know I
wanted to feather and tar our
transgender people and I specifically
argued that all people deserve to be
treated equally under the law but we
don't have to uniquely celebrate your
personhood right there's a distinction
between treating you as an equal member
of society and having to go an extra
mile to uniquely celebrate your person
I'll give you another example yeah
Canada wanted to now create a
gender-neutral Society so the idea being
that the marker male or female say on
official government documents should be
removed because that small percentage
less than 1% substantially less than 1%
who consider themselves non-gendered or
non-binary are going to feel
marginalized by having to write male or
female so 99.9% of a population should
lose an identifying marker that is part
of their personhood I am a male I have a
child that's male I have a daughter
that's female a married to a woman
that's female all of these things should
be removed because someone might be
marginalized by that biological reality
it's insanity so for someone like you
that deals in academia but more
importantly that deals in the realm of
science and you have to base things on
fact this is actually a direct assault
on you in a certain way right like
you're like you're talking about
something that's important to say but
really it's rational self-interest you
want to be able to do your job that you
have been trained to do at the highest
level without having outside fears so
when you finished up that talk over
there did you feel better or worse for
the course of it I felt better and
at least my positions were on record I
didn't have any sense that the bill
would be defeated I felt very strongly
that it would ultimately pass just
because of the the reality of dynamics
of the political system there but at
least I knew that Jordan had been heard
I had been heard it's officially on
record so in that sense I felt I had
done my quote civic duty yeah but I had
no illusions that I would help sway the
vote I knew that we would ultimately
lose the bomb so when people say I'll
see online sometimes you'll say oh you
guys are overestimating when someone
says racist or bigoted or home before
were islamaphobe or any of this stuff
this really goes to show why these are
not we're not just making up this fight
this fight forget what people are saying
online this fight is now starting to
codify things into law that absolutely
right I mean but never mind law I mean
people say but you know don't take these
extreme examples well you had Brett
Weinstein on the show I mean is he not a
real person who's experienced real death
threat so people always think that we're
in a sense engaging an exaggerated
narrative by pointing to these extreme
cases but what is extreme today Tabora
becomes mundane and so this is why
Canaries in the coal mine stand up and
sing and warn people
but unfortunately apparently people
don't want to listen do you ever think
that it's kind of kind of sucky to be
someone that sees something a little bit
early I think it's sometimes like it's
great at a certain level right because
that's what makes people care about what
you're saying because they have a they
have a twinge about that guy's on to
something but like when I sat here with
Brett and he at the tie I don't know
what he identifies as now by the time he
was saying I'm a you know he said a
deeply I think deeply committed
progressive I now know that he at least
I almost peak one but basically has said
you know the progressive train has left
him right um or or he grew up Oh perhaps
I don't know that he would say it so
specifically but but I knew it as I was
sitting here with him and he was saying
how he was this deep progressive I knew
that it was just a matter of a month or
two months or whatever before he'd see
the same the thing that we've all been
talking about for that long so there's
there's like a joy and also like a
depression in that
well my wife often tells me that I'm an
avant-garde both and my scientific
career and my primary engagements I
think it's in part because I do see
these trends early but also because I
have the courage to speak about them you
and I might both see them at the same
time but if I only have the courage to
say it then I appear as though I'm the
avant-garde guy whereas you saw the same
pattern but we're too afraid to say it
yeah and so in a sense it's a unique
combination of both seeing these
patterns early enough but then having
the courage to to voice my opinion and
of course that ultimately in academia is
not something contrary to what you might
think is not something that's desired
herd mentality is really as we say in
French dirty-girl it's the it's the
official way to be don't cause too much
ways we don't want trouble here right
which is so the reverse of what true
pursuit of knowledge is so when people
say that I'll also hear that well you're
you guys are over blowing what's
happening on college campuses or you're
over blowing that there isn't enough
diversity of thought there as someone
that's on college campuses as someone
that is testified about what's happening
there and as someone that knows plenty
of academics in Canada and the United
States are we over blowing this
absolutely not I mean when it comes to
issues like political matters how people
make pronouncements about a given
religion or date or not there is app
every buddy walks the exact same beat
again I could just use for example
anecdotal evidence or I could cite
actual studies but let's go with
anecdotal evidence and I think I might
have mentioned this before on the show
if you just go to my personal Facebook
page you will never see anyone and I've
got hundreds of academic friends on my
personal Facebook page not a single
person has ever uttered a position
regarding say Trump that I would
construe as surprising surprising in the
sense that they might say something that
is positive of him or favourable and why
someone might have voted for him every
single academic friend that I have Apes
the identical same position and that's
simply not possible right within any
group of people you would expect some
diversity of thinking well apparently
there isn't all right so let's talk
about Trump a little bit now I want to
be clear that right now as we tape this
I am about to go off the grid for a
month so this is going up about 12 or 13
days
stur we're taping this so in the way
that we live these days Trump could have
done anything by them the impeachment
proceedings could have been begun the
monarchy could have started who the hell
knows what's going to happen but as we
tape this on what today July 28th right
2017 I think you've been basically
pretty fair on Trump I don't sense that
you love the guy no but I don't sense
that you're to have a deranged hatred of
the guy right is that a fair estimation
yet that's exactly right and usually
when I've come out quote and support of
Trump that's not usually what I've done
instead I have offered very reasonable
psychological reasons why someone might
vote for Trump and so I you may remember
this in one of my conversations I think
it was with Sam Harris where I explained
the actual decision rule that someone
might use in arriving at a decision to
vote for Trump and I'll just repeat it
yeah but really here so when you're when
you're choosing between two multi
attribute products to cause to people to
hire to mates to marry they're each
defined by many attributes so there are
many decision rules that I could use in
deciding whether to choose alternative a
or other and be one of these decision
rules is called the lexicographic rule
which basically says take your most
important attribute to you and choose
the alternative that scores higher on
that most important attribute that's the
only thing you look at so in the case of
applying that rule to Trump if let's say
my most important attribute my
lexicographic rule attribute is
immigration and rightly or wrongly I
view that Trump scores better on
immigration and if I use that rule and I
will choose Trump even though if I had
looked at all of the attributes defining
Trump and Clinton
I might have ended up choosing Clinton
so as someone who studies psychology
decision making there are very very
clear cognitive processes that we could
use to explain why a very reasonable
person might end up choosing Trump now
that doesn't mean that I as I jokingly
say on Twitter that I have posters of
Trump and my bedroom it simply means
that as someone who is dispassionate who
is studying it from my Canadian context
as a behavioral decision theorist I
could
understand why people would vote for
Trump just uttering that the amount of
hate that you get and the amount of you
know ostracizing that happens within
academia because you dare say something
that seems to support Trump it means
craziness how much of that do you think
is sort of the elitism of academia in
other words you're saying something
that's that you're using you're the
discipline that you have to give this
idea of why people may have voted for
Trump
so you're separating sort of the the gag
human part using this is this is what I
think is happening based on information
that I have versus other academics that
because they want to go to all the
parties with the academics and all of
that stuff that Trump is sort of the
reverse academic so the idea that they
could say anything nice about the person
who's the reverse who speaks in such
ridiculous speech patterns and says so
many over-the-top things and tweets like
a madman that somehow that would all be
thrust upon them right the way that I
would frame exactly what you said is the
elitist the academics the ivory tower
folks excuse me they view Trump as a
fatal attack on their sense of
aesthetics it's he is the injury to
their aesthetic the way he speaks the
way he enunciates the way he shakes
hands everything about him is an affront
to their haughtiness and therefore there
is this visceral hate of him at an
aesthetic level he's grotesque he's an
ogre he's a buffoon and I see this this
position enunciated amongst some of our
common friends yeah where I typically
would consider those friends to be those
common friends to be very sophisticated
dispassionate thinkers but they've
succumbed to that trap where they are
simply unable to stomach the possibility
that this person could be sitting in the
highest office I think it really is that
simple they despise his sense of
aesthetics so I sense that your position
on him is sort of where mine is in that
forgetting what I think about him
personally and again I could say the
phrase moral Center every time I bring
them up again don't know what is moral
sentries I'm still confused as whether
he's waking up every day
a and making all the decisions as they
come on the fly or if there's a grand
plan or any of that but the part that I
like is the part that the media has
taken it on the chin and basically been
blown apart and that I think is what we
needed in this country I sense you're
kind of with me on absolutely look at to
use a cliche that I don't particularly
like from sort of the buzzwords of
business he is a disrupter right to the
extent that you wanted someone funny
because they they all love disruptors
but now they but now and again you're
going to get a disrupter I don't like
right I mean he's a disruptor in every
possible way that you could conceive of
that term right
he's from outside the political class
he's never held political office he
speaks differently from them he's a
brawler he's a real-estate guy his is
his language pattern is that of a thug
in grade eight he is somewhat buffoonish
so in every possible way that we could
think of what they aspire to
you know Barack Obama he's the anti
Barack Obama Barack Obama is
sophisticated his majestic he's a great
orator right but again those are
superficial cues right typically when we
when we look at psychology of persuasion
we look at substantive cues or cosmetic
use right how tall you are is something
that people use when they judge your
leadership qualities but it's
objectively it shouldn't matter right
and so in a similar manner the fact that
he might speak in a way that is clearly
much more buffoonish than say Barack
Obama doesn't necessarily speak to
whether you appreciate his policies or
not yeah and that's the part that I
think is interesting because again as I
said we're taping it's about two weeks
before it's going to air so who the hell
knows what's going to happen but even
just in the last couple days there was
this thing with with scar Meucci yes and
all that the recording and you know
Bannon wants to suck his own [ __ ] and
blah blah all the stuff and everyone's
freaking out I'm looking at Twitter and
all the journalists all the lefties
everyone's freaking out over the
language and how can I talk like this
and all I was thinking was yeah I mean I
guess in some perfect world that we
don't exist I wish that government
officials would be a little more
professional but the idea that Obama
people and Bush before that and Clinton
before that and you can go back forever
literally go back round George
Washington the idea
they didn't speak it with blue language
and say nasty things about each other
and and all of that stuff and in
fighting back the idea that this has
just appeared now it's just it's just
all-out race it's just fake it's full
outrage again it's trying to maintain
the facade of the ivory tower right this
highfalutin way of baloney I mean I
wasn't that Nixon who when you look at
his his transcripts every second word
every I have that yeah yeah these guys
are not oxford professors of philosophy
and by the way I wouldn't want them to
be I want them to be human that that's
also the irony it's like when Bill
Clinton said I don't inhale it was like
you could admit you inhale or when Baco
bomb I guess did say inhale but it's
like the idea that we have to feel
guilty about all of these things like
we're all humans we curse some of us
drink or smoke pot or do some other [ __ ]
and just to mention a couple of other
qualities that I think Trump does have
you know when you face a lot of
conflicts there do some research I
remember who it's by I think it's made
by Greg brewery at Texas Tech if I'm not
mistaken he looked at what what types of
leaders do people wish to elect as a
function of the environment is there for
example war or not and so our preference
for a particular type of leadership
style changes as a function of the
environment as you would expect well to
the extent that we now face a lot of
chaos with terrorism with the
immigration problems and so on I would
have predicted that someone like Trump a
guy who appears to be a bit reckless it
appears to be as though am I going to
press the red button am I not going to
press it even though he's not going but
the fact that he he exudes those types
of signals I think to a lot of people
that is equality because you have very
dangerous guys in the neighborhood who
might feel intimidated by someone who
appears to be a risk taker who appears
to be a brawler and so in that sense
here's another psychological reason why
a lot of people might have latched on to
him so it also goes to show why when
Obama or Hillary wouldn't say radical
Islam right terror or whatever phrase
that you wanted to say and Trump would
just say anything it chump is just
giving them the red meat they were going
give me something give me something that
makes sense then Trump says I mean it's
probably all
the top right what they're going well at
least it's something exactly right I
should mention I know that we both
tentatively we that's talked much about
Islam before the show but let me just
mention one or two things yeah I think
it is a misnomer to constantly come up
with qualifies before the word Islam and
let me explain why that is
there is no Islam there is no Islamism
Islamism is part of Islam Islam is a set
of codified ideas that has a spiritual
element and it has a political element
that political element is Islamism the
manner in which now people are talking
about Islamism is it's something that is
outside of Islam and I understand the
reason why people want to do this is
because they feel as though it's too
gauche to frontally attack a religion so
if you attack something that has
magically is M at the end of it Islamism
that's okay if you attack Islam that's
not okay but the reality is if we're
truly going to have a serious and honest
conversation about this topic we have to
recognize that it's not radical Islam
it's not Islamism it's not militant
violent extremism and and every other
permutation of a euphemism that you come
up with
it's Islam now most people choose to
practice a cafeteria version of Islam
they pick the parts that they like and
they ignore the endless parts that they
don't like and that becomes their
personal relationship with Islam yeah
that does it and that but most people do
that with most religions or most people
that with most version but I don't you
and I and everybody else don't stay up
worrying about seventh they added this
so to the extent that Islam is now on
the radar and we have to talk about it
honestly we have to stop trying to give
a free pass to Islam but the real
problem is something else some variant
of it yeah Islam is codified in the
Quran it's codified in the Hadees it's
korra file in ceará the biography of
muhammad that's it now is there a way
that I could read those texts and come
up with a message of brotherly love and
love for Jews no that's not Islamism
that's not radical Islam that's Islam
now as I say this I also recognize that
95% of all Muslims are just as nice as
anybody that you could hope to have
that's not because they practice a
gentle version of Islam codified in
other set of text that's because they're
decent human beings who decide to like
the rest of us they can choose which
parts apply to their daily lives or not
so we have to be very careful and honest
about it and I hope that at some point
soon a greater number of our common
friends will actually heed what I'm
saying now yeah by the way for the
record because you just mentioned that
we said we were going to talk but that
much about ISM it's not because we're
afraid I think we both yes we both
talked about a point 10 but we realized
if we wanted to get more into some
science stuff and plenty of other stuff
I swear I just want to be clear because
otherwise people come on you say they're
afraid now alright so but it's very
quickly on that though so you are
writing a new book right now yes which
deals with this and deals with ostrich
parasitic syndrome so very quickly for
those that don't know what o-p-s is
let's talk about that then I will talk
about the book and then we'll move sure
I'm sure thanks for asking uh so let me
sort of step back and give some some
analogies so if you look in the animal
kingdom there are many cases where you
have brain worms or pathogens that enter
the brain of a particular species and it
renders that species zombified okay so
example a mouse can be infected by
particular pathogen it loses its innate
fear of cats that's not a good thing if
you remember right there is another type
of brain worm that attacks the brains of
ungulates let's say moose or elk or deer
and they become they become completely
zombified when they just circle in the
same in the same spot until these
looming predators come and eat them
right think of another example of
someone who suffers from anorexia
nervosa right they they're thinking now
has become so disordered that even
though they only weigh 70 pounds they
look at themselves in the mirror and
they genuinely think that they are they
remain grotesquely obese they need to
lose a bit more weight right so there
are all sorts of ways there are so all
sorts of analogies where whether it be
in the human context or with other
species where our brain become hijacked
by either disordered thinking or
literally a pathogen so I took these
ideas and I argued well what could
explain the collective psychosis the
collective departure from reason that we
see being exhibited in the West
not only as related to Islam but as
relating for example to
negation of the idea that humans are
biological beings that there are sex
differences they are male so this
ostrich parasitic syndrome is not only
applicable to Islam and so that's how I
came up with that term to to to use the
metaphor of the ostrich buries its head
even though it doesn't truly do that but
it's an apt metaphor of the denial of
reality parasitic in that it genuinely
parasitizes your brain and you lose your
ability to think now
I specifically apply it to Islam because
typically the ostriches that succumb to
o-p-s come engage in all sorts of
cognitive distortions to protect Islam
right which ironically you're talking
about people that are not Muslim for the
most part right absolutely so so many of
the OPF sufferers will end up being
non-muslims who because they've been
parasitized by o-p-s will come up with
all sorts of disordered thinking to
defend Islam right and I give many many
of such examples now I take this idea
and it's part of my book so the book is
tentatively titled death of the West by
a thousand cuts this is the idea that we
we are currently facing this o-p-s
epidemic because of a perfect confluence
of full intellectual movements that have
parasitize our brains so it's not one
thing it's radical feminism its identity
politics its cultural and moral
relativism its post-modernism each of
which uses its own machinery to
parasitize our brain to move away from
reason right I reject the idea that
there's male and female
well evolutionary biologist and
evolution psychologists don't write here
I reject that they are innate sex
differences while the average
three-year-old knows that there is such
a thing I reject that there is any link
between Islam and any terrorism Islam is
peace right so how did we lead to this
what we let we were led to this by 40 50
years of these movements chipping away
at our commitment to reason and hence
death of the West by a thousand cuts so
what was the failure of the site of
reason and for the last 40 or 50 years
what did the people that were reasonable
that were sensible in trying to deal
with things honestly and
the world as it is not how they wanted
it to be where did they fail well I so
if I say if I speak in the academic
ecosystem I think the fact that we
tolerated these these affront to human
decency and human reason like
post-modernism to exist it really came
from a place of you know we have to
tolerate in this case the intolerable
the intolerable in that nothing could be
further from being anti-scientific than
post-modernism what does post-modernism
say there are no objective truths other
than of course the one truth that they
are narrator they rather than the thing
you really gotta be laughing yeah so
post-modernism and all of its endless
full profundity and you know full
nonsense is really a direct attack on
science right science presumes that
there are certain universal regularities
that we're going to use a scientific
method to try to better understand well
imagine if now a bunch of nihilists come
along who say there is no such thing as
true there is no such thing as objective
truth
well that chips away at the reason why
we all exist in science to try to
understand the world how would academia
academia fight that properly if the idea
is we have to battle at you know I know
we both believe in the Battle of ideas
so if the if the idea here is that in
colleges you're supposed to have these
battles I know you beat it with better
ideas but how how would that have
actually happened well I think what what
probably ended up happening I mean I'm
I'm I'm surmising here I'm not sure how
it happened but I'm guessing that most
people are busy in their daily lives
right that for the same reasons why most
people don't speak out against Islam but
you know let Dave Rubin worry about that
that that's someone else we're thrilled
right I'm busy preparing for my
daughter's graduation I got to pick up
the tomatoes for my groceries today
right and so people diffuse
responsibilities to others so in a sense
there's a split within academia from the
sciences the natural and Social Sciences
by the way is wrong to presume that the
social sciences are any less committed
to the scientific method in the Natural
Sciences which is up to that we could
say I do want to get right after that
people are busy right so the chemist
sits in his lab and he's
is that there's a bunch of humanities
guys uttering utter you know gibberish
right well you don't necessarily have
the time and energy and proclivity to
weigh in on it and so somehow these guys
found a little niche within the
ecosystem called academia and they
flourished and they multiplied and the
cancer spread and metastasize and now
4050 years later you have generations of
students who spend hundreds of thousands
of dollars being trained to be naturally
lobotomized morons yeah you know it's so
the metaphor is perfect of this parasite
that gets in there and keeps multiplying
and I can picture now the the biology
professor going alright I kind of see
that but it's not going to affect me
here except now what we're seeing is
it's starting to even creep into that
have you seen this there's this great
picture online of you know somebody
selling the shirt that says there are no
genders but you can only buy it in mail
or yell if it's like there you go
alright so let's talk about the Natural
Sciences versus the social sciences
first for the layman what is the
difference they both have science and
again come on
right so the late the layperson will
often use these sort of simplifying
heuristics to determine what is science
versus not if you're wearing a lab coat
if you have a configuration right if you
have a couple of chemical formulas
that's science because of the average
layperson that's impenetrable on the
other hand most people have for example
a folk psychology they have an innate
sense of what psychology is and
therefore to the extent that they feel
that they could contribute even though
they might be laypeople somehow that's
less impenetrable to them right so they
then will create this false dichotomy
where chemistry and physics
that's real science but sociology you
know it's for people who couldn't hack
it in physics the reality is that the
only difference is what are the
phenomena that you're studying across
these two general rubrics of science in
the social sciences you're studying
psychology anthropology economics
sociology it could be as rigorous as the
Natural Sciences so let me give you an
example if you could if you're a
sociologist you could study social my
tree which is you know for example how
this power diffuse with
network and you could use very fancy
mathematics graph theory to try to
understand it so the type of
mathematical modeling that you would use
to study how power diffuses within a
network is actually a very fancy
mathematical approach but sociology has
somehow been co-opted by the activists
right yeah so we then view it as being
less scientific but sciences simply
means adhering truthfully to the
scientific method I posit a hypothesis I
think about the data that I would need
to collect that would either falsify or
not hypothesis I collect that data I
apply some sort of statistical analysis
some mathematical analysis to analyze
the data and then I go one way or the
other that could be just as applied if
it's in economics or if it is in physics
so it is wrong because I often get
letters and emails from people asking me
what a psychology really is science and
of course it's an AI yeah well
ultimately what is more laudable than
studying the most important organism
that we know called humans right yeah so
so it's not as though by the sheer
nature of what physicists study they are
real scientists but the sociologist is
not and by the way I'm not trying to
defend sociologists here because I often
am the one who's criticizing since I
usually I'm criticizing them for
deviating from the scientific method
what makes them less scientist is that
they become activists and not scientists
but you could be just as much as a
scientist if you study something in
business or if you study something in
chemistry yeah it's interesting that you
talk about activists not scientists
because that's what I've been saying
about journalists these people are not
doing true journalism and fact-finding
anymore in reporting my son based on
evidence what they're doing is letting
their own biases slam right into the
middle of anything and so far so one of
the things that I will say
differentiates the science the Natural
Sciences from the social sciences and
that's very much at the heart of the
work that I do the Natural Sciences have
organized trees of knowledge so in
physics people agree on a set of core
knowledge that at this point has become
unassailable
not withstanding the fact that they
still have the epistemic ability to say
oh if new provision it's only
provisional if something now falsifies
it I'm willing to revise it right there
is but the bedrock the bedrock there
there's core knowledge that is now
unassailable in physics and chemistry
there aren't chemists who are for the
periodic table chemical are against the
red right therefore you could build
coherent trees of knowledge or the term
that I love to use which was
reintroduced into the common lexicon by
EO Wilson the evolutionary biologist at
Harvard its conciliate unity of
knowledge so the Natural Sciences by the
by the nature of how they test theories
have these organized trees of knowledge
that's what's lacking the social
sciences and the results lacking is not
because the social sciences are any less
scientific it's because it is easier for
ideologies to creep into the social
sciences right so if I'm a libertarian
or a Marxist I might study economics in
a way that is very polluted by my
personal ideology so it's not that the
social sciences are epistemological II
any inherently less scientific than
chemistry is that biases are easier to
creep in yeah it's funny because out
here and I talk to sometimes someone's a
leftist economist or libertarian
economist or whatever it is I always
think it's kind of funny like we all
have our own beliefs economically I'm a
little more libertarian these days but
if you're studying something within the
window of the way you want it to be it
by default is going to be a little
screwy absolutely and as I said it is
naturally more difficult for your
personal ideological biases to come into
something that you're studying in
organic chemistry although I should
mention that there have been famous
cases where even hard sciences have been
deeply polluted by ideologies so licen
Co ism like Sanko was a Russian Soviet
Union geneticist who proposed a theory
of genetics that he thought was more in
line with Marxist philosophy that was a
wrong theory of genetics that led to a
massive famine
and to the death of millions of people
so even it's not as though hard
scientists are inoculated from the
possibility of being parasitized by some
of these ideological biases do you think
it's too late for the hard sciences to
be protected like is it too late for
them to turn their forcefield on because
we do see this creeping now in biology I
mean bright white signs I'm talking
about this now but now it's really
reaching its hand into that which could
have horrific repercussions well listen
when when I want a scientist in the 21st
century I'm speaking of myself and now
has to appear in front of the Canadian
Senate to argue that there's such a
thing as male and female yeah that
evolutionary biology is based on the
recognition that there is sexual
dimorphism and human sexual dimorphism
is a fancy term for saying basically
that they are evolved sex differences
humans men
males are bigger than females right
that's a sexual dimorphism so the fact
that I have to appear in front the
Canadian Senate to actually argue these
things demonstrates how far the snake
has gone into the den yeah so in a weird
way your position as a evolutionary
biologist is a is sort of right at the
front of the type of person that this
ideology would attack right just agree
I'm an evolution cyclist I cough I are I
just said buy out you guys although I
apply evolutionary biological program oh
yeah I mean it's craziness right and and
the reason why I'm so if you like aware
of the the epidemiological dichotomy
between the natural and Social Sciences
is because my scientific career of
20-plus years has really been straddling
both these fields right I apply
evolutionary biology to study consumer
behavior consumer behavior would be
construed as something within the social
sciences evolutionary biology is
something that is within the Natural
Sciences so I really am very much
steeped in both cultures and I see the
extent to which it is easier for people
to succumb to their personal biases and
the social sciences let me just give you
one example yeah if you start off with
the premise that you can't agree on
whether there is such a thing as innate
sex differences or not how could you
from that starting point ever build a
tree of knowledge that's organized if
at this most fundamental level we can't
agree that there is such a thing as male
of female then we're done we're cooked
physicists don't suffer from that
problem and that's why they make much
better progress than then social
scientists do so as someone that studies
marketing and why we behave how we do
what turns us on what turns us off all
of that in a weird way you were you were
prepared for everything that was going
to happen politically right now and
what's happening on the academic front
because all of these things they're all
marketing in a way Trump its marketing
Hilary Market heard yourself in it in a
certain way so the trends were all their
life and marketing yeah so when people
ask you so what do you study as as a
professor of marketing and I always
answer them everything I do in life is
marketing you market yourself on the
mating market we even use the euphemisms
of the marketplace right you know you
position yourself in the marketplace you
market yourself in the labor market you
market yourself to friends you position
yourself depending on whether you wish
to belong to a group or not animals
communicate with each other right when
when animals advertise for example when
the peacock the peacock is literally
engaging in conspicuous advertisements
and so everything in life is marketing
so one of the reasons why I was very
much interested in applying all of my
training in marketing is because that's
I think where all the sexy stuff is
right we take all of these principles
from psychology from economics from
biology and then I apply them in areas
that our greatest import to most people
if there's something kind of scary about
that though that it's not that the best
ideas will necessarily win it's that the
best marketed ideas will win and those
often are not the same thing very good
point listen I'm right now working on my
next book and I just connected with a
what appears to be a wonderful literary
agent and he actually made this exact
point he said look what's really
important as we move forward your book
is how to market it because there'll be
people who will be very resistant to the
ideas that you propose in that book so
again everything is marketing so
basically if you want to did Trump do
you think have not to bring everything
back in but he must have had I guess as
a businessman and putting his name all
these things for the last 30 years he
had an innate understanding of exactly
what you're talking about
absolutely well is it I could speak to
one thing that he didn't very well he
could completely read that many people
the silent majority or certainly a
sizable minority if we're going to use
the popular vote of rhetoric were fed up
with political correctness and said I'm
going to be the anti PC guy and he bet
pretty much everything on that and it
turns out that people responded to it
right
he could have equivocated he could have
been more careful with his words but he
sort of he flies off the handle because
he realized that the general atmosphere
was most people whether they're having
chats on facebook or at the workplace by
the water cooler at the university are
tired of feeling stifle are tired of
feeling scared of the next syllable that
they might miss utter that might ruin
their careers and he said I am the anti
PC warrior and people respond to that
marketing position so someone that
studies all the stuff what do you think
people really drives people at the end
of the day you know I mentioned before
as I say often I think it's just a
couple things you want have a job you
want have some money hopefully a house
maybe a family maybe some sex whatever
job eight the basic stuff of it all and
do you think those are really just like
desires so in in several of my books I
actually answer that question in the
following way I map consumption acts on
to four key Darwinian modules so think
about how math those hierarchies move if
you know it yes so at the basic level
there's the physiological needs and then
belonging that your safety needs
belonging this needs all the way up to
self-actualization well his theory was
really based on his humanistic
philosophy in other words he had this
bias this this ideological bias of how
humans should be it wasn't necessarily
grounded in an understanding of biology
so I took this principle and I said no
let's see what actually drives people
based on biological principles and so by
for Darwinian modules are the survival
module so a lot of things that we do are
related to our survival instincts so our
preference for fatty foods right why is
it that it's
for us to succumb to the desert effect
having an extra piece of desert when
we've already had more calories than we
need to well that comes from the fact
that our gustatory preferences have
evolved in an environment of caloric
scarcity and caloric uncertainty so your
taste buds in mine are vestiges of an
environment long gone but that we've
evolved to have but can your brain
evolved to override that let me think
okay that's actually called the mismatch
hypothesis I'll come to in a sec okay so
first we've got survival then we've got
reproduction everything relate to sex
why do men why are 99% of Ferrari owners
male because that's the form of
peacocking so then Peacocks tail is
literally the aston martin that men
drive right yeah and of course both men
and women engage in sexual signaling so
first we've got survival instinct we've
got reproduction then we've got kin
selection kin selection is the mechanism
that explains why is it that I would
jump into the river to save three of my
brothers if all I care about is my
survivability why would I ever take the
risk on it well when you realize that a
natural selection operates at the level
of the gene then saving three brothers
each of whom share half the genes with
me makes sense now you might say well
how do you find out a consumer behavior
well gift-giving practices right so how
i modeli the size of the gift that I
give to different people turns out to be
perfectly correlated to the genetic
relatedness with each of these people I
give larger gifts to my brother than I
do to my second cousin I may not do this
consciously and I may not know all these
fancy theories I'm doing it but our
brains have evolved to recognize that
people are not of equal genetic
relatedness and the fourth module is
reciprocal altruism okay I jump into the
river to save three brothers but why
would I jump in to save Dave Reuben he's
not my brother well that comes from this
evolved idea of tit for tat I scratch
your back you scratch mine well today I
might jump to save you with the
expectation that tomorrow when I'm
drowning hopefully you'll come and save
me so this idea of reciprocity has
evolved for social species and again it
explains why I will invite you out for
dinner when it's your birthday and you
will hopefully reciprocate when it's
mine from a strict economic perspective
there's no point to this right let's not
invite each other we'll be at the same
final position the reason why we do this
exchange is to oil
friendship in our bond so I argue that
much of consumer behavior could be
mapped onto these four modules so now to
your other question ya know it is very
difficult for our brain to catch up to a
current reality so for example men have
evolved sexual territoriality as a as a
strong element of their psychology right
they don't like women to be promiscuous
if they would then they get they get
sexually jealous if another man touches
their woman and so on well why would
that have evolved that goes both ways
right and in women interestingly okay so
that's okay I'm not interesting right
yeah this is not my way this is David
buses work a colleague evolution
psychologist at the University of Texas
Austin he looked at with some of his
colleagues at romantic infidelity versus
sexual infidelity so he brought in
people to the lab he he set them up with
all sorts of physiological measures to
measure their stress and have them read
one of two vignettes
your your husband right now is having
sex with the gorgeous secretary versus
your husband is developing an emotional
bond with his coworker she laughs at his
jokes they get a lot so in one case we
trigger sexual infidelity and the other
one romantic infidelity well it turns
out that women respond much more
adversely to romantic infidelity than to
sexual infidelity and that effect is
reversed for men now that doesn't mean
that women appreciate sexual infidelity
or are tolerant of it but it's less so
now what are the reasons for it well it
turns out that sexual infidelity is a
profoundly important evolutionary
problem for men because we're by
parental species where males invest a
lot of their children it doesn't make a
lot of sense for me to invest for many
many years until little Johnny grows up
to be sexually mature to then find out
that it was the sexy Greek or Roman
gardener who sired that guy right
therefore I evolved this the the
psychological apparatus to try to
protect against this possibility so I am
very empowering of sexual infidelity if
a woman cheats on a man it almost
guarantees the end of the solution the
other way around it doesn't on the other
hand what's the greatest threat to a
woman's interests it's not that he
has a sexual valiance one time this is
why men very naively often will say I
just had sex with her once she meant
nothing to me they actually think that
this is helping because there is no
emotional bond between us it's a
one-time thing right on the other hand
if a man develops a emotional tie with a
woman that's a much greater predictor of
him leaving the relationship and that's
why women respond so adversely to
emotional infidelity but if a man says
well it was just a one-time thing isn't
he then let's assume it's the truth for
a second guy says at one time he's
telling the woman what she wants to hear
right I mean what what if it's true for
him it's also what she does want to hear
because she doesn't want to hear low
absolutely it's certainly much better
for him to be right it was a one-time
thing rather than I think I'm falling
for her and we're planning on having sex
with another 37 times but he genuinely
is trying to convey to her that she
literally meant nothing to him he's
perfectly able to decouple the sexual
act from any emotional investment right
eat what you think about what Jon's will
go see prostitutes what do they
typically tell you it's perfectly
unencumbered sex and I'm able to have
sex with her and walk away I pay for
that walking away right so again that
speaks to evolved sex differences this
whole conversation that we've had might
be transphobic systemic violence on
their bill c16 says look I didn't talk
about the non gender or non-binary yeah
I must be a genocide supporter naturally
but I'm glad you just mentioned that
because as you're saying is I'm not even
exactly sure what my question is but is
there an element as you're sitting
across from a gay person that enters
some of this great question I don't
think we finished the mismatch question
yeah okay wait let's get to that let me
first and then we'll talk about
homosexual I'm giving me a lot here
about lettuce yeah that's what I wanted
to do the science that's why we're here
yeah beautiful thank you so our brains
don't catch up as quickly as we
otherwise would want so for example the
fact that look the top killers the top
medical killers are colon cancer heart
disease diabetes from an evolutionary
medicine perspective the argument is
that it stems
from the fact that today we live in an
environment of Plenty but our gustatory
preferences have evolved in an
environment of caloric scarcity and
uncertainty that mismatch between our
current environment of Plenty and the
environment in which we've evolved
causes some of these top killers so to
answer your question in a long-winded
way no our brains don't catch up if
there were selection pressures for the
next X number of years to cause an
evolutionary trajectory to change that
it would happen but typically for even
the most basic genetic selection
it might take say five thousand years
right so I guess what I'm talking about
then is for the person that never goes
to the desert or never engines on this
or that that's not an evolutionary thing
as much as it's someone that's aware
it's someone that's educated and aware
of that these things can cause health
problems and you might be like I live
here in LA where everyone doesn't eat
this or that or doesn't want gluten
everyone's everyone has celiac disease
which no one has celiac disease I mean
so that's not evolution that's just sort
of doing something different with the
information you have right it's not on
the macro level and evolutionary well
and sometimes you have multiple
Darwinian poles pulling you in different
directions so that the net effect is
zero so for example when I explain why
there are evolutionary pressures for
both men and women to cheat on their
long-term partners that doesn't mean
that it's a fatalistic argument it's not
biological determinism we're doomed to
cheat because we also have evolved the
moral calculus right our morality unless
you're a religious person that thinks
that it comes from God our morality has
also evolved through the exact same
evolutionary forces that explain why we
have opposable thumbs and so on the one
hand I'd like to very much cheat on my
wife on the other hand I've got this
moral catalyst that stops you from doing
the net effect is that I might actually
not do it so this speaks to a really
important point which is the fact that
you explain something from an
evolutionary perspective doesn't mean
that it is biologically fatalistic got
it all right so how much sexual yes now
if we add that into this mix
you're talking about here so the the top
theory that has been proposed that has
not the data has not cooperated comes
from actually kin selection so let me
explain it's a bit technical yeah so you
could increase your fitness in other
words you could you could extend your
genes through direct reproduction that's
called direct Fitness right if I have
children I'm extending my genes but I
could also if you like increase my
inclusive fitness by investing in those
who are related to me when I when I
invest in my nephews I am indirectly
extending my genes correct so the
argument then is that that homosexuality
need not be a Darwinian Kilda sock
meaning a Darwinian dead end because
even though you may decide to not have
children by investing in your kin you
could still be extending your genes now
how would you test this idea well you
would take for example homosexual uncles
and heterosexual uncles and see if the
homosexual uncle's invest more in their
nephews and nieces and if the answer
would be yes then that would be one data
point that supports the idea I have
taught my nephew everything I know about
Star Wars and I am very bad at working
your nose every year right yeah but the
data has not supported that so the
bottom line is the top argument the top
ever lose weight the data has not
supported but that that actually
happened exactly not really the Kinze
the kin selection based argument for
homosexuality while at the theoretical
level conceptually sounds good yeah the
data has not supported that so that's as
far as I know about the nexus between
homosexuality and evolution although I
think we might have mentioned this when
you came on my show I do have a current
doctoral student who is actually
planning on studying in his doctoral
dissertation the intersection between
get ready for this homosexuality
evolutionary psychology and consumer
behavior how is that going to work so
we're going to look at phenomena that
typically happened between men and women
and for example if you go out on a first
date the best way to never have a second
date in the heterosexual context is for
a man to be cheap on the first date
right
that's guarantee anyway
the woman is a billionaire if he
exhibits cues of frugality its debt yeah
okay so then let's take this idea and
see whether within the context of the
dynamics of homosexual relationship when
it when two men go out on a date for the
first time good we see a replication of
this phenomenon but now there isn't
male/female here so what would be the
proxy measure pop bottom yeah so good
for example your sexual as either a
predominantly top or predominantly
bottom replicate the sex differences
that we typically see at the
interactions between men and women what
do you really think of that by the way
well I don't know that it's so
interesting because I don't know that
your sexual position has anything to do
with how you necessarily on a date would
say I'm going to pay or not pay I don't
I get where I get this you're saying
that basically the the top is or
anything than the masculine right I get
I mean I guess it's ugly
that's what I would have guessed did I
not say that but I don't know that we're
going to test something let's take
another example of exactly this idea so
when when men and women mate there's
what's called a sort of mating so birds
of a feather flock together
so typically women it's not that women
want necessarily tall guys is that they
want a taller guy so it just it's very
rare for a woman to date someone shorter
than her so there's actually a study
that was done with 720
naturally-occurring couples only one of
the 720 was the woman taller than the
man really yeah it's a quite critics
extraordinary rare so let's now let's
apply that to almost nine and done the
research but here's my hypothesis yeah I
bet that the top bottom distinction will
determine the height thing in other
words if the the bottom guy will be in a
long-term Union in a matter meeting in
the gay sauna for success yeah long term
period met you know a marriage he'll be
the shorter guy so a lot of the
phenomena that we would pick up some
evolutionary psychology as applied to
heterosexual context will replicate in
the homosexual context so I'm curious
all this being said as you said you're
hypothesizing about some of this stuff
and and obviously your your student is
going to work on some of this in other
people organism is
is there a complication that links
everything else we've been talking about
where if you talk about gay anything
that this could get you in some sort of
trouble I don't sense you feel that as
you're talking about it that there would
be some piece of this that you might
find something that would lead you to
somewhere uncomfortable or something it
the context lack of the email yeah I
don't mean you personally up well but I
actually think that if you do any
research right now on any of the LGBTQ
things that would be a very good thing
because you would be somehow labeled as
a progressive so in the context of the
equalist that you came to a conclusion
or degree that was not politically
correct yeah yes so that speaks to
actually an issue that I've discussed
with several folks and I think perhaps
maybe Sam Harris mentioned that when he
had me on his show he was asking me is
there any research that you would get
and I water KF u'b is very complicated
okay so maybe we can get into that at
and the the term that I had used with
him then which came from a paper that
was published in nature forbidden
knowledge no I am a strong non proponent
of the idea forbidden knowledge if
research is done honestly assiduously
with full adherence to the scientific
method then there is no question that is
too taboo to to ask that actually speaks
to something in philosophy the
difference between the in collage achill
ethics and consequentialist ethics the
ontology collects is the following it is
never okay to lie that's a deontological
statement a consequentialist ethics
statement would say well it might be
okay to lie depending on the
consequences of the lie right right if
it's going to cause 20 people to die
exactly so one is an absolutist
perspective one is it's a situation on
depends on the consequences so I will
use that framework to answer the the
forbidden taboo question of what kind of
research is okay or not yeah if you are
a purist a deontological epithermal
logical person I do research wherever it
takes me then you don't care about the
consequences if you are consequentialist
bent then you say well but if we do race
differences and the results come out in
a way that it could be used to harm a
racial group then we should stay away
from it I actually think that that's a
profoundly danger
position to take because it's precisely
this type of argument that led the
Social Sciences to reject biology as
being important the the early
anthropologist cultural anthropologist
who said biology doesn't matter for
humans we're coming from an honorable
place because they saw how cretins could
misuse biology right the Nazis can say
hey there's a battle between the races
and it's a Darwinian struggle
we're Aryan we won who cares and let the
Jews die the British social class
elitist said there's a battle between
the social classes the lower class has
lost screw them it's a Darwinian
struggle of course this has nothing to
do with Darwin but because these folks
misappropriate misappropriated
biological thinking then the cultural
anthropologist came along and said let's
get rid of biology because then nobody
could misuse it and now we're in the
quagmire where we are today where we
have to appear in front of the Canadian
Senate to argue that there is such a
thing as male or female so know if you
are a purist you pursue knowledge
wherever it takes you unencumbered by
the consequences is the problem that I
suppose a certain amount of people
scientists included probably think that
they're purist but actually aren't you
know it mean like so so Mengele probably
thought that you know who is doing all
sorts of you went all not yeah yeah I
we're not yeah in this particular case I
feel a Nazi references out it is
actually sensible as opposed to Nazi
references that are thrown around all
day long but but if you think about that
I mean Mengele was doing horrific
experiments on on twins and just all
sorts of things that were considered
beyond imagination horrible probably
believed that he was doing it for the
good of truth and the good of science
and all that I don't you know to me as I
her resume have been a horrific person I
don't think he it is hard he probably
thought he was doing good though right
so the only thing that I would say that
would stop that from happening now is
that we do have institutional review
boards or ethics boards now that ensure
that there is a boundary on the
scientific pursuits that you could well
pursue and that is you know you can't
previously harm animals the way you
treat them in the law
is important you can't frivolously harm
both physically and or psychologically
human subjects right but answers
interestingly though now they've gone
overboard so the institutional review
boards now have become so aware to want
to be the antithesis of manga lay so
that now if I ask you what is your deck
that's right so that could be
traumatizing if I ask you what is your
income well weight in some cultures
that's an affront and that could send
the person into a tailspin of suicide
because I asked them what his income is
and so now the most banal innocuous
questions have to be discussed for
seventy three thousand years and these
institutional review boards so I think
the fulcrum not swung too far the other
way so that it is now stopping good
science from being done because we are
so afraid of harming any Third Way so
the good intention of we actually don't
want to harm this animal or we don't
want to inject the dye into a human's
eye that my blind 'im has become now we
don't want to offend this person exactly
right this is a huge jump that dangerous
residing absolutely and frankly I see
the fear in my graduate students but
they're about to apply for a thesis
grant because they've heard all these
horror stories that they come to me as a
professor sad how long is the process
going to take and I always answer them
it really depends on the makeup of the
folks that are going to review your
application if they are perfectly
reasonable people it might go through in
a session if they are absolute maniacs
it might take us three months of
rewriting this damn thing for some guy
to finally accept that you know we're
not injecting dye in people's face and
the reality is most of the research that
I get involved in although it's you know
very rigorous and scientific really has
no downstream harm that's going to be
caused
but it's unbelievable the types of
concerns that people raise and and we
need to rail that rain that in a bit
yeah I want to have a little bit about
robotics which I've never even mentioned
the phrase robot to you or any of that
stuff but there is something about we're
getting into this time with incredible
automation and we know about you know
cars that are driving themselves and we
know that you know
people i pads are going to put
McDonald's employees out of business and
all of this stuff how will that affect
the way we evolved how to like now that
we're going to add this thing that is
completely artificial and outside of us
is there an evolutionary piece to that
or is that something else altogether I
think it's something because for
evolution to to work right there there
has to be a selection environment that
is if I'm bored let me for your viewers
who may not know how evolution works I
done explained it three seconds ok let
you a male and a female get together
through sexual reproduction they have an
offspring this random combination and
shuffling of genes results in their
offspring having a blue dot here if that
blue dot is heritable it could be passed
on and if that blue dot confers a
survival advantage to the animal then
this selection pressures are in place
for eventually that blue dot to become
part of the makeup of that species so to
answer your question you would have to
explain to me how there are specific
selection pressures that affect the
survivability of an organism or its
reproductive viability for me to be able
to offer an evolution even right now I
can't take that one because I mean that
does make sense
I feel I can't end this on a question
that we would say doesn't make sense
perfectly so I will ask you this and
we're going to do this many more times
you'll do this again any time I'm here
all right
taking everything we've discussed here
are you hopeful or not for the future of
the West do you think we are just caught
in sort of this leftist postmodernist
stuff versus a nationalism or a populism
that could be dangerous
or do you think that the Enlightenment
values that you care about in liberalism
and all that actually has a chance to
turn this tougher so here's a now where
I need to put on my marketing hat oh
yeah
as in sell it brother exactly so if I'm
going to speak about some of the times
when I see the tsunami of ostrich
thinking that comes my way then I feel
very pessimistic I feel as though an
utter disaster has to happen before
people wake up on the other hand because
I'd like to have the hope and market
hope I think that it doesn't take
too much to redress the ship if enough
silent people silent voices rise up in
every ecosystem on Facebook on them in
the media in academia at the bar and
actually the you know trigger the
courage that is necessary for them to
weigh in I think that the voices the
enemies of reason will become
marginalized but we need to rise up and
that's why I always tell people when
they ask me well what can I do
I said well you don't have to have the
voice of Dave Rubin or the platform of
the ruin you just have to have enough
courage to take on your friends when
you're engaging them on Facebook when
your professor says something that seems
like it's an affront to Reason challenge
him or her don't be silent so I think
that if enough people do that then the
ship can be addressed if we remain
apathetic then I think we will lose yeah
I totally agree and as I always say I'm
one guy that started a channel on
YouTube
you're one guy who started a channel on
YouTube we came for very different
places and and if our voices have done a
little something then there's plenty of
other people that can replicate and
brother as well all right I think you
guys know where his channel is but if
not check out dad's YouTube channel at
youtube.com slash get set
[Music]
you